[Music]
who'd like to hear some christmas carols
last christmas me and bob worked on the
streets
[Music]
happy christmas i thought you could use
some christmas cheer
there's a lot of things i could use
right now getting my gas and hot water
back on
[Music]
that cat does not look happy to me
[Music]
can you control your dog i wanted to
chat to you about a couple of concerns
you can't take them away from me
if a guy who works on the street is
being separated from his cat at
christmas
it's got to be done by the book
you've got to help me i'm threatening to
take bob away maybe they should
anyone who knows the man and the cat get
in touch you have proved your love a
hundred times over it's not normal for a
cat to be out in the streets james gives
bob the choice to stay at home
or go out with him and every day bob
goes with him
i dreamt of snow back when i wasn't why
is it always about you james what so
good
breaking they took everything come on my
way
angels are all around us if we just know
where to look
[Music]
christmas isn't a season it's a feeling
[Music]
whatever form your family takes
[Music]
that's what christmas is about
[Music]
you